[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce sky échos le magazine qui vous
racontent la vie des acteurs économiques
du territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines bâtir des territoires de
confiance le nom de l'événement durant
lequel nous enregistrons cette émission
de nombreux acteurs des nouvelles
technologies du numérique et des
collectivités locales se sont donné
rendez vous au théâtre national de
montigny le bretonneux
objectif échanger sur leurs expériences
leurs besoins dans le digital et la
cybersécurité la cybersécurité il en
sera grandement question dans ce 24e
numéro du sky échos le campus cyber
ouvrira ses portes à la défense en
janvier 2022 acteurs de la cybersécurité
implantée à montigny le bretonneux
l'entreprise numérique ses parties
prenantes elle développe aussi des
solutions dans ce domaine un centre de
formation dédiée à la cybersécurité le
principe de l'école de 1600 installé à
montigny le bretonneux elle a ouvert ses
portes en septembre 2021 l'événement sky
emploi fait sa rentrée se déroulera du
18 au 21 octobre un rendez vous pour les
demandeurs d'emploi et des entreprises
du territoire
saint quentin en yvelines et le
groupement des industriels français de
la défense et de la sécurité terrestre
aéroterrestre ont organisé le mardi 21
septembre au théâtre national de
montigny le bretonneux une matinée des
échanges sur les enjeux de la
cybersécurité du numérique pour les
collectivités locales retour sur cet
événement dans cet instinct échos
[Musique]
nous assistons à une révolution
numérique qui aboutit à numériser
l'ensemble des secteurs de la société ce
matin on en parlait de façon générique
pour l'ensemble des collectivités
locales est donc une nécessité absolue
afin d'accompagner en fait la gestion du
numérique avec une vigilance accrue sur
la cyber menaces
[Musique]
la plateforme a pour objectif de fédérer
les données qui sont les données et les
sous systèmes qui sont déjà disposés
dans les villes ça peut être une caméra
de vidéo protection
mais ça peut aussi être un détecteur de
bruit cet ensemble là va permettre de
dire il ya un bruit anormal à un moment
donné dans la journée est-ce que c'est
pas un chantier pirate est ce que ce
n'est pas une fête où est-ce que c'est
pas un incident qui s'est produit
[Musique]
e
ah ah
aujourd'hui 9000 postes sont en tension
dans le domaine de la cybersécurité face
à ce constat l'école de 1600 a ouvert
ses portes début septembre 2021 cet
établissement forme des jeunes âgés de
16 à 30 ans aux métiers de la cyber
sécurité ces locaux sont installés à
montigny le bretonneux découverte de cet
établissement dans ce décryptage
[Musique]
on a choisi le modèle de l'alternance
pour pour pour deux raisons la première
c'est que nous ne souhaitions pas qu'ils
aient de barrières financières à
l'entrée ont souhaité répondre à un
besoin urgent de compétences des
entreprises
[Musique]
on
toutes les entreprises aujourd'hui
quelle que soit la taille des
entreprises puisque une tpe
malheureusement des tpe se font aussi
attaqué et c'est dramatique ou des pme
pour lesquelles c'est dramatique aussi
jusqu'aux grands groupes effectivement
tous secteurs confondus on va former des
experts en cybersécurité c'est à dire
des gens qui vont à la fois comprendre
les besoins de production de l'industrie
mais avec ce souci de caisse que
potentiellement peut mal se passer et
être exploitées à des fins malveillantes
[Musique]
c'est une entreprise unis montel
spécialisée dans la transformation
digitale numérique s'accompagne ses
clients dans le déploiement de
technologies numériques cette entreprise
franco tunisienne de 160 collaborateurs
proposent des formations et développe
des solutions dernier en date un
dispositif en cybersécurité les détails
dans cette séquence en immersion
[Musique]
nous sommes au siège de numerix
entreprise spécialisée dans la
transformation digitale est situé à
montigny le bretonneux
parmi ces activités il ya la cyber
sécurité et dernières technologies
développées imparfait pour lutter contre
les attaques informatiques pour en
parler nous sommes avec un maître
bouaziz bonjour bonjour et bienvenue
chez nous
merci de nous recevoir et donc vous êtes
le responsable de la recherche et du
développement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler de ce pare-feu donc ce
firewall alors nous travaillerons
s'appelle dms estevan dms pour dire
double masque c'est une nouvelle
technologie qui a été breveté de
filtrage des règles sur les firewalls
aujourd'hui et donc nous utilisons cette
innovation cette nouvelle technologie
pour permettre plus de performances plus
de stabilité plus de sécurisation sur
les équipements informatiques donc en
gros l'idée c'est d'éviter toute attaque
informatique comment ça fonctionne
concrètement sur un ordinateur
aujourd'hui nous avons accès depuis une
interface web sur l'ensemble des modèles
et outils d'administration
de notre firewall donc nous avons un
tableau de bord globale qui nous permet
de voir l'utilisation les taux de
saturation de stockage et de ressources
globalement sur notre freeroll on a
aussi la possibilité de gérer plusieurs
typologies d'interface réseau donc avec
plusieurs types de configurations et
c'est ces configurations là nous
permettent derrière d'éditer des règles
de filtrage qui vont être traitées avec
notre filtre à jp à double masque pour
permettre aux plus de performances comme
nous pouvons le voir ici nous avons
l'option fils tripp et à double masque
qui nous permet donc
fils tripp et à double masque qui nous
permet de voir des gains réels par
rapport aux failles rôle classique donc
ses gains de performances peuvent
atteindre les 90% aujourd'hui merci à m
oasis pour ses explications vers cerveau
et on va rejoindre tout de suite ahmed
aboul hadid qui va nous expliquer que
ben numérique s'est engagé aussi dans
d'autres offres concernant la
cybersécurité et parmi les autres offres
dans la cyber pour numérique s'il ya
aussi des formations et numérique s'est
engagé est partie prenante du campus
cyber qui ouvrira en janvier 2022 à la
défense et pour en parler nous sommes
avec ahmed aboul adil bonjour bonjour
le responsable cybersécurité chez
numerix alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer en quoi vous êtes partie
prenante du projet de ce campus cyber
alors tout à fait non numerix a souhaité
intégrer et rejoindre justement le
campus cyber le combustible r c'est une
volonté donc qui avait piloté et j'irai
mis en place par là par là par la
présidence donc le président a décidé de
mettre une souveraineté au niveau de la
cyber sécurité sur le territoire
français et numérique s'est impliqué
justement a souhaité rejoindre sète ce
projet là concrètement vous allez y
faire quoi concrètement numériques sont
rejoints cette cette organisation pour
pouvoir participer au développement être
un des acteurs dans le monde de la
cybersécurité en france et participer à
des ateliers de la recherche et
d'innovation autour de la cyber sécurité
numérique aujourd'hui c'est quoi dans
l'information en cybersécurité
numerix a décidé depuis plusieurs années
d'investir sur la formation que ce soit
pour les clients ou pour les
collaborateurs ces formations sont
orientés dans la cyber sécurité sur tout
ce qui est la gestion la vulnérabilité
la montée en compétences aujourd'hui sur
les enjeux de la sécurisation des
infrastructures et des réseaux merci
ahmed aboul a dit le responsable
cybersécurité chez numérique merci
depuis sa création en 2012 numerix
accompagne les entreprises dans leur
transformation digitale
160 collaborateurs engagés au quotidien
près de 8 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires par an pour en parler nous
sommes avec son pdg mon des rails a dit
bonjour bonjour
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'évolution
de votre société est cotée donc
effectivement depuis 2002 là aujourd'hui
donc on a effecté mois donc on devient
donc une sorte de pme grosses pme déjà
établi à l'international aujourd'hui
numériques ses actifs bien entendu sur
la fonction mention digital donc c'est
avec quatre corps de métiers qui sont là
dit la transformation digitale qui sont
la cible à sécurité qui sont
effectivement la recherche et
développement et au cinéma à
l'université un organisme de formation
spécialisés dans la cybersécurité dans
le management et dans les technologies
microsoft est aussi open source on l'a
vu vous développez vos solutions en
cybersécurité avec le fireball vous
proposer des formations mais le corps de
votre métier c'est aussi d'envoyer des
consultants dans les entreprises c'est
ça bah écoutez le corps de notre métier
c'est le service à proprement dit donc
le service aujourd'hui se transforme et
ceux effectivement se met en place selon
trois niveaux donc on a affecté moi bien
entendu donc le haut conseil et si notre
expert effectivement qui va travailler
chez nos clients nos clients dans le
secteur automobile que notamment
notamment renault notamment le groupe
bastide en tice dans le secteur banque
assurance dans le secteur public mais
aussi dans le secteur du telecom donc
aujourd'hui donc ça c'est effectivement
notre expertise là où elle va
actuellement essentiellement dans la
région parisienne mais aussi sur la
france le deuxième positionnement donc
c'est c'est le forfait c'est à partir du
moment qu'on s'engage sur des résultats
par rapport effectivement dans 41 ma
technique bien défini et le troisième
niveau a2 service c'est la tm la tierce
maintenance applicative c'est à partir
du monde on comprend des projets et on
assure la maintenance corrective et
évolutive
quelle honte est l'évolution dans les
prochaines années chez numérique bah
écoutez je pense que là à la crise couve
et d'être passé par là on a
effectivement donc atteint et atteint
donc une certaine résilience par rapport
aux activités donc on a gardé on va dire
leur chiffre d'affaires 2010 9 g ctive
mandant qu'on a fait le même en 2020 et
pour nous c'est un exploit là on repart
à la croissance donc avec 15% et
prévision de 15 % de croissance sur
l'année 2021 aujourd'hui on est déjà à
l'international donc on a déjà attaqué
le continent africain avec un hub vient
délivrer center qui existe en tunisie et
nous aussi donc l'afrique sub-saharienne
pour nous donc c'est important pour la
suite de notre positionnement notre
notre vocation internationale qu'elle
est aussi européenne bien entendu
effectivement donc on sait dhabi de plus
en plus en france et bien entendu donc
on va ya effectivement dans qu'à des
niveaux de croissance qui sont au moins
égale par rapport à ce qu'on a fait
entre 2010 et 2018 et 2018 2019 merci
mon derrière dit merci beaucoup p dg de
numerix entreprises unis monteyne
spécialisée dans la transformation
digitale à noter dans vos agendas
l'événement sky emploi fait sa rentrée
du 18 au 21 octobre plusieurs rendez
vous dédié à l'emploi sont proposés des
ateliers des webinaires des conférences
et pour conclure le 21 octobre un nid
job dating est organisée si vous êtes
candidat ou dirigeants si vous
recherchez un emploi ou si vous
souhaitez trouver de nouveaux
collaborateurs pour votre entreprise est
bien inscrivez vous sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas d'écran c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi une émission que vous pouvez
revoir en replay sur notre site internet
ou sur l'application mobile à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]